leute bleibt auf jeden fall bis zum ende
dran weil ihr könnt noch was cooles
gewinnen also dran beim viel spaß mit
dem video
okay aber ich bin wirklich gratis
geschenk für dich also das ohne zwar
[Musik]
etwas gedacht im netz bekommen beim ein
video wie alt ich hoffe euch gut gestern
mal hier in köln der elfte und alle
gehen wie am 11 11 im karneval feiern
weil am elften elften karneval anfängt
das war so krass ist ja zum ersten mal
so miterlebt und ja irgendwie ganz
verrückt also ich hab kein weg ist noch
nie so voll ist irgendwie geht es dann
darum sollte man aber eigentlich gar
nicht gehen und zwar haben wir sonntag
den 12 elfen und heute kommt die neue
kollektion heraus endlich aber wir
machen heute noch so ein kleines schult
eng mit ein paar instagram an hier in
köln und so weiter also dafür muss ich
auch gleich losfahren
die anderen abholen bevor wir das
allerdings machen muss ich euch mal kurz
was zeigen und zwar war das eigentlich
mehr lustig ich wusste zwar dass noch
ein paket kommt aber ich dachte ich
werde es niemals bekommen weil samstags
kommt fast nie pakete und ich war
gestern den ganzen tag nicht da das gut
ist jetzt aber es hat irgendwie
geklingelt so um keine ahnung 20 uhr ich
bin gerade wieder zurückgekommen habe
mich umgezogen und normalerweise immer
wenn es klingelt kann man halt durch die
kamera sehen wer unten vor der tür ist
da war aber niemand und ich dachte so
herr ok mache einfach mal so unsere
wohnungstür auf so eine unterhose wird
sich da so ein typ ich habe deinen paket
ich dafür sei dank
auf jeden fall ist dass das paket hier
sind noch einige coole sachen drin die
wir heute brauchen sind allerdings
frauen sachen also ich kann damit nicht
viel anfangen mariscal ausstellung
kommen also die kommt heute auch mit und
ich habe mir gedacht ein kommen
längst jedoch mal so ein kleines
geschenk dafür dass wir unter ex frau
mit kommen und so weiter das ding ist
aber ich habe auch noch so ein zweites
paket und das tue ich jetzt einfach eine
banane rein und irgendwas anderes und
gehe erstmal das geschenk ja ich hoffe
natürlich sie wird sich freuen dass hier
ist übrigens der shop aber wenn der
online geht die danach aus als jetzt
gerade ist nun übergangs bild und das
hier ist jetzt das geschenk was ich
gerade einfach mal zusammen gestellt
habt als halbwegs der größte müll drin
wird wahrscheinlich denken was will er
zu mir du kannst du mal kurz ich habe
ein fettes geschenk für dich
diesmal aus das ist heftig und zwar habe
ich mir gedacht weil du wirklich so cool
ist und so denke ich dir mal ein paar
sachen aus meinem was ich halt alles
noch so gefunden habe was da ich damit
du dich warum es ist wird das ist das
von das ist dass du spiel von paola
maria ihr okay aber ich habe wirklich
ein großes geschenk für dich also jetzt
ohne spaß
das ist ein richtiges geschenk
jelinek ich bin heute so lieb ich schenk
dir mal was bitte schön hast du eine
ahnung was das sein könnte
es ist wertvoll du denkst es
wahrscheinlich dass nur irgendwie
stoppen oder so aber das ist wirklich
was richtig richtig kasse alte leute ich
weiß selber nicht was drin ist aber
manchmal vielleicht dass hier auch was
ja ich habe es zwar erwarte dass nicht
mal das sind jetzt sachen die sehe ich
jetzt gerade zum allerersten mal also
das sind meine sachen und ich bin ich
also das sind nicht meine sache nochmal
zeigt nochmal wie findet ihr einfach
diese sticker ich habe jetzt schon so
oft gesehen aber mir fällt gerade erst
auf dass sich die mega cool finde nein
das ist nichts für frauen
ich dachte da wäre eine andere mütze
dabei die müssen wir gleich noch
aufsetzen
hier hast du auch noch was vergessen
[Musik]
ach so das sind halt alles sachen die
ich schenke ich dir jetzt ne geile
sachen guglwald klamotten waldenburg
klamotten machen wir überall morgen
läuft und wir machen jetzt folgendes
jedes mal raus und ich zeige euch mal
die klamotten wie die aussehen mal
vielleicht als kleines beispiel also
wenn es noch nicht kannte das ist ja
auch von der kollektion das war aber die
alte kollektion des sugar und das was
ich dir jetzt geschenkt habt das ist von
cherrys so heißt es
[Musik]
so leute ich will jetzt gerade die
anderen vom hauptbahnhof ab wie man
sieht perfektes wetter in köln
ja es ist einfach den ganzen tag schon
am regnen aber was willst du machen so
leute ich hab die drei jetzt abgeholt
wir haben hinten einmal peyton reed auf
das video habe ich dann besser jetzt auf
jeden fall drin und aktionen
der kümmert sich jetzt um das ganze was
beim ipad abgeben und felix vielleicht
kennt ihr dennoch so johann wir brauchen
jetzt wird's grün jetzt musst du mich
einmal johann wir brauchen jetzt noch
erstmal einen vierten gutscheinkarte
würde ich mal sagen
alex w oder so weil wenn ihr jetzt die
nächsten 48 stunden alex w halt benutzen
als gutschein code und doch irgendwas
kauft kriegt die wie viel prozent
höchster porzellan und ich hab ja am
anfang schon gesagt es gibt noch eine
verlosung hass wegen welche teile hier
dabei gerade oder im kofferraum
ok dann zeigen wir euch gleich noch ein
zwei teilchen
und die können wir dann gewinnen aber
dazu gleich mehr so leute also johann
hat jetzt nicht hier sachen rausgesucht
die wir verlosen werden das ganze kommt
übrigens heute um 19 uhr online also
sitzen also das ganze kommt 17 online
der shop ist in der video beschreibung
natürlich verlinkt wir sagen das einzige
was wir machen müssen um an der
verlosung teilzunehmen ist ein moment
sein meine mir fünf euro ich bin dann
auf das video licon kommentieren ein
spaß ihr müsst nur in die kommentare
schreiben was wir der gerne davon haben
wollt und wir sagen auch den daumen nach
oben geben also einmal diesen centro die
hier schreibt einfach hashtag karamell
in die kommentare wenn ihr den haben
wollt und darum gehen danach für die
girls ich ist mir heißt das neue coupé
shirt kokos und was ist ganz bitter
schaut euch das mal hier wertverlust und
zwar an ist sich hierbei um diese schöne
mütze bis wir auch mal aussetzen also so
kann das aussehen dann schreibt einfach
mütze mit sind also sitzen wo ist das
ganze online ich weiß nicht wann dieses
video kommt aber vielleicht auch erst um
17 uhr legen erst ein paar schöne fotos
machen und wir sehen uns dann morgen
eventuell wieder wünsche euch einen
traumhaften tag und kaufte ein 15
prozent rabatt mit alex wie
gutscheincode und bei denen die dann so
rudi gewinnen lege ich extra und sticker
mit dazu und wenn ihr wollt dann
schreibe ich alex sah